foreign
[Music]
construction of EDC teaches you how to
manage construction projects
successfully today
pretty much all the project management
books you can buy today were written
without considering the combined impact
and opportunities of information
Technologies like building information
modeling the Advent of modern management
methods like lean construction and new
collaboration methods and Technologies
VDC brings these Concepts together and
applies them separately and jointly to
the management of the design
construction operation of buildings
plans infrastructure and other
constructed facilities
[Music]
the most unique thing about the VDC
program is that it's learning by doing
and that's the core Foundation of it
people bring their own challenges from
the daily work from their companies from
their building projects construction
sites and we give them a set of tools
and we coach them to improve their
project and they do this on a daily
basis actually when you get negative
results it's where you learn the most
and that's when you have to take more
actions and by doing that you experience
and learn and improve
foreign
it has impacted my personal career quite
a lot actually it kind of helped my
company to become more competitive it
helped my company to get a better
reputation having in my career uh
a story program from Stanford has been
an outstanding achievement for me
personally the opportunities and the
mindset shift that they will gain from
learning BDC at this young stage of
their career will absolutely impact the
rest of it
[Music]
it gives you the opportunity to share
knowledge with people from all over the
world it's amazing because from Latin
America we are from Chile or Peru or
Colombian but
we meet people from Norway for
Switzerland we are actually affecting
how we execute projects all around the
world and that aspect is really cool to
have uh like a framework that Embraces
everything for multiple cultures in
different parts around the world
it's amazing
there is a lot of inspiration what would
never happen when I just look a YouTube
video or have a short online
conversation with a friend who runs the
same company so this is the inspiration
you will get here and the mind opening
setting you feel like a family here you
have a big brother like a mentors and
you are the younger sister
there are plenty of programs around
digital transformation for construction
but this is one of a kind because it
sees the project as a whole and it
brings everything together and we need
everything to be very successful and
that was for me mind-blowing actually
if you're interested and you get the
chance take it